now to Ukraine where Russian drones
targeted the capital key for a third
straight night Ukrainian officials say
one person was killed in the latest
attacks and claimed their forces shot
down nearly all the Russian missiles
meanwhile officials in Moscow report
minor damages and injuries from a drone
attack that Russia blames on Ukraine
Deborah patters in Ukraine has the
latest on the air attacks
the wave of Russian Russian strikes in
daylight and at night time has been
relentless
pre-dawn explosions once again in cave
when a swarm of exploding drones was
taken down by Ukraine's air defense
network the third attack in just 24
hours
yesterday morning children were sent
screaming in Terror
residents scrambled into underground
shelters as a barrage of Russian
missiles bore down on the capital
president of a Vladimir zielinski hailed
the success of the U.S made Patriot air
defense system
when Patriots are in Ukrainian hands he
said there is a 100 interception rate of
any Russian missile
but as each side in this conflict tries
to gain the upper hand ahead of a
looming counter-offensive even Moscow is
starting to feel the Direct effects of
this wall
according to Russian media more than 10
drones targeted the capital today
with around 300 people evacuated from a
high-rise building after it was damaged
in the attack
zielinski's presidential advisor says
while they are watching the attacks with
pleasure and believe they will increase
Ukraine has nothing to do with them for
CBS mornings Deborah patter heart Keith